>> IF YOU ARE SHOCKED BY THESE
IMAGES, GET USED TO IT.
PANAMA IS WARNING 50,000 MOSTLY
HAITIAN MIGRANTS ARE HEADING
NORTH.
THAT IS DOUBLE THE NUMBER AND WE
SAW CROSSING DEL RIO.
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY IS REPORTEDLY PREPARING
FOR A RECORD SURGE AT THE BORDER
IN OCTOBER.
I WONDER WHY.
COME ON DOWN.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
I HEARD THE PANAMANIAN WOMEN,
THAT WE PICK YOU BIDEN, MONTHS
AGO, AND JOE DID NOT LISTEN.
THAT SOUND FAMILIAR TO YOU GUYS?
MENTIONED MICK WANT THEM ABOUT
WHAT HIS TOP DOLLAR NUMBER IT
WAS IN JULY.
WHAT THIS HE DO ALL DAY?
HE SITS IN HIS SOFT CHAIR AND
LET'S SUSAN RICE WHEN THE
COUNTRY.
YOU THINK YOU CAN TURN TEXAS
BLUE?
THAT IS THE GOAL.
IT IS GOING DEEP RED IN THE
SHORT-TERM.
POLL CAME OUT.
TEXAS, IT HAS BEEN EXPECTED 30%
APPROVAL WITH TEXAS HISPANICS.
ONLY 25% OF TEXAS HISPANICS
SUPPORT WHAT JOE BIDEN IS DOING
ON THE BORDER RIGHT NOW.
IS SUCH A GIFT FROM THE GAVE
THIS GUY JOE IS SPITTING ON.
LET THEM STAY IN MEXICO AND
APPLY FOR ASYLUM THERE.
WE HAVE SO MUCH LEVERAGE OVER
OUR SOUTHERN NEIGHBOR.
HUNDREDS OF BILLIONS OF TRADES
WITH MEXICO.
WE PROTECT THEIR SECURITY.
AND HOW ABOUT THE VACCINE
DIPLOMACY?
IF I WAS JOE BIDEN, I WOULD SAY,
YOU ARE A COUNTRY WITH 130
PEOPLE.
WE JUST GAVE THEM A MILLION
COVID SHOTS.
I WOULD DANGLE ABOUT 20 MILLION
MORE SHOTS OVER MEXICO CITY.
I WOULD SAY, WE DO THE STUFF YOU
GUYS.
ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IS STOP THE
CARAVANS.
WHY DOESN'T HE THINK OF THAT?
>> WHY DOESN'T HE THINK OF THAT?
>> IF I CAN THINK OF IT, SURELY
JOE CAN.
>> THERE IS A MEETING NEXT WEEK.
THEY ARE ALL HEADING DOWN TO
MEXICO CITY TO HAVE A CHAT ABOUT
WHAT IS GOING ON.
IT WILL BE INTERESTING TO SEE
WHAT THE NEWS IS THERE.
WE ARE NOT SURE IF THEY WILL
TALK ABOUT IMMIGRATION.
THEY ARE GOING TO BE TALKING
ABOUT IMMIGRATION.
AND WE CAN'T JUST TELL MEXICO TO
KEEP EVERYBODY.
THERE HAS TO BE INCENTIVES TO DO
THAT.
WE HAVE TO BROKER SOME SORT OF
NEW DEAL THAT IS GOING TO
CORRECT.
RIGHT NOW, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS IN COURT OVER
THE REMAIN IN MEXICO POLICY.
THEY DID NOT WANT PEOPLE TO
FREELY CROSS OR HANG OUT AT
MEXICO FRANKLY WITH THE DISEASE.
BUT IT WILL BE INTERESTING TO
SEE WHAT COMES OUT OF THAT
MEETING.
>> MEANTIME, YOU WANT TO TALK
ABOUT THE DEMONIZATION OF BORDER
PATROL DEMONIZATION OF BORDER
PATROL.
WHAT DOES THAT DO TO PROTECT
ENFORCEMENT?
IT DISCOURAGES ANYBODY FROM
JOINING THE PATROL AND IT PUTS
PEOPLE BACK ON THEIR HEELS.
>> I REMEMBER BEING IN THE
FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT TRAINING
CENTER.
THE USUALLY THAT BECAUSE
CONSTITUENTS.
ON THE BEACONS TO WHEN YOU ARE
UP, YOU HANG OUT.
THEY WERE GREAT GUYS AND WOMEN
WHO DID IT.
YOU THINK.
WHY DON'T YOU DO THIS ANYMORE?
CAN WE JUST PLEASE, I MEAN, STOP
THIS SILLINESS THAT THERE'S A
SOUTHERN BORDER?
WHAT DOES A BORDER?
DO YOU UNDERSTAND THE DEFINITION
OF A BORDER?
IT IS A DELINEATION WRITE NECK.
HERE'S OUR COUNTRY BUT HERE'S
YOURS.
OF THE THEORY IS, THE CONTENT OF
WALKED BACK AND FORTH -- AND
WHEN YOU COME IN WE WILL GIVE
YOU BENEFITS AS WELL.
WHY ARE YOU EVEN THINK IT IS A
BORDER?
THE BORDERS NOT DESIGNED TO BE A
SUGGESTIONS.
TO THE DEMOCRATS ON DISK I GET
TIRED OF THIS WHOLE IDEA, BUDGET
SHOWS.
SO THE HIGHEST NUMBERS WE HAVE
WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP AND BORDERS
ENCOUNTERS.
60,000.
WE HAD ABOUT 180 TEMP OF 200,000
A MONTH OVER OBAMA.
WHAT DO CAN HE CAN HAPPEN?
WE TOLD EVERYBODY TO COME HERE.
DEMOCRATS ARE NOT DONE.
YOU THINK THE DON'T KNOW THIS?
THIS IS CLEARLY INTENTIONAL.
AND WE SHOULD STOP PRETENDING IT
IS NOT.
>> AND SPEAKING OF WHICH,
ACCORDING TO MAYORKAS WAS ABOUT
350 TO 400,000 MIGRANTS
POSSIBLY.
IN OCTOBER.
THAT IS THE -- EXPECTABLE.
>> EXACTLY.
I HAVE A HARD TIME, MARTHA,
ORGANIZING COMMUNICATIVE SMALL
GATHERING -- FAMILY GATHERING TO
GO TO DINNER.
TO GO OUT TO A RESTAURANT.
HOW IS IT THAT THESE TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE MANAGING TO
MAKE THEIR WAY FROM ALL THESE
COUNTRIES AND SUCH AN ORGANIZED
FASHION, MAKING IT INTO THE
UNITED STATES?
EXPECT BECAUSE NOW IS THE TIME.
MOST OF THEM HAVE BEEN IN THESE
COUNTRIES FOR 2 OR THREE YEARS.
AND THEY LOOK AT WHAT HAPPENED.
THEY HEAR WHAT MAYORKAS SAYS.
THEY SEE WITH THEIR OWN EYES AND
THAT IS THAT THEIR RELATIVES AND
PEOPLE THAT THE NOTE ARE GETTING
IN AND WHO CAN BLAME THEM FOR
WANTING TO BECOME?
BUT THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS
THAT JOE BIDEN SAID DURING THE
CAMPAIGN, WE COULD IN A
HEARTBEAT TAKE 2 MILLION.
HER NUMBERS ARE TOO LOW IN TERMS
OF WHO WE ARE TAKING AN.
THE STRATEGY HAS BEEN QUITE
CLEAR PROTECTORS TO ALLOW PEOPLE
TO COME.
AND PARTLY FOR THEM, WE HAD A
DRONE AT THE SOUTHERN BORDER AND
WE HAD IMAGES THAT WERE CAPTURED
BY THAT ON THAT STARTED TO
CHANGE PEOPLE'S OPINIONS.
WHAT IS HAPPENING IN TEXAS IS
SOMETHING THAT THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY -- THERE ARE THREE VERY
CONCERTED CONGRESSIONAL PRODUCED
CONTESTED CONGRESSIONAL RACES.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT HISPANIC VOTERS
WHO ARE INCREASINGLY WANTING TO
ELECT A REPUBLICAN OR SOMEONE
WHO IS GOING TO TAKE THE BORDER
SERIOUSLY, IF YOU HAVE A VERY
INTERESTING TREND.
THE LAST ELECTION, PRESIDENT
TRUMP, MORE HISPANIC VOTE IN THE
PRIOR ELECTIONS.
AND IN THAT ELECTION, HE GOT
MORE THAN'S PREVIOUS REPUBLICANS
HAD BEFORE.
SO WATCH THESE TRENDS BECAUSE
THIS IS NOT SOMETHING THAT IS
POPULAR WITH VOTERS WHO HAVE
BEEN TYPICALLY DEMOCRATIC
VOTERS.
>> AND TALKING ABOUT INCENTIVES,
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS CAN GET MORE
THAN $15,000.
>> WHY WOULDN'T YOU COME?
>> 15 GRANT.